وقبل ايام فقط حتى انصاره على التظاهر
مغذيا ومعديا ذلك بامكانيه اعتقاله لكن
الرئيس الامريكي السابق ترامب يبدو اكثر
ارتياحا اليوم طبعا حيث رجح ترامب اسقاط
المدعي العام في منهات القضيه المرفوعه
ضده نظرا الى عدم امتلاكه اي شيء ضده وفق
تعبيره طبعا واستخدم الرئيس الامريكي
السابق اول حشد كبير في حملته للانتخابات
الرئاسيه المقبله لينصف نفسه باكثر الرجال
براءه في التاريخ الامريكي ويصف القاضيه
بالفارغه والمزوره هذا واكد ان تحقيقات
الجنائيه معه بشان شراء صمت ممثله اباحيه
كانت سوء سلوك ادعاء وفقه صحيفه ديليت
الاجراف مكتب المدعي العام من جهه رفض
التعليق على هذه التصريحات علما بان هيئه
المحلفين ستستانف عملها طبعا يوم غد وقد
يتم توجيه الاتهام الى ترامب الاسبوع
المقبل